hi
i'm eduardo cerna i work in the
probability statistics group
a welfare mr consultant uh i imagine
most of you attending this talk just
came back from
just came from my colleagues talk which
i couldn't attend all of it because i
was getting
ready for this one um but i know the
content and hopefully means that i don't
have to
introduce every concept um
i'm going to be talking about the
model side of uh
this spatial statistics new framework
that we're
finally releasing after a lot of work uh
a lot
some of you might have attended previous
talk on this this time
it's coming out um
so i'm just gonna just give an overview
of the of the process side of things uh
kosair was talking mostly about data or
she also
mentioned uh processes a little bit um
so i just wanna
first of all i just wanna motivate why
we want to deal not just with
with data um but with processes
and process allow us to really um
make conferences about uh the real world
um an insane population or the
underlying mechanism that is causing a
phenomenon
and spatial point processes allow us to
model
um an increasingly pervasive array of
geospatial data
human activity natural resources
resources epidemiology
stuff like that um this is this is stuff
that is becoming
um very important nowadays and very big
data sets
are coming online people are very
interested in this um
and we have for now
focused on three types there's different
types of families and models we have
uh for this iteration of of the
framework we
focus on three types of models uh
porcelain models which are the simplest
ones um
where points are independent from each
other we also have
uh pairwise interacting processes called
gibbs process
um and these are the simplest type
processes where points are not
independent of each other
and we also have a as a different type
of interact
of non-independent process called
cluster processes
and although there's although they're
they're technically a subset of
interacting processes but these
are not necessarily pairwise and and
here
in these type of processes points are
generated around
seeds that then generate a cluster
i'm going to talk about all of these
three families giving examples with data
and trying to show some toy applications
so the poisson processes
the poisson family of processes
we have three processes implemented the
poisson point process which is the
simplest one
canonical one we have a constant point
density these all of these processes
generate
all of these processes generate um
generate a collection of points where
the numbers
might not be fixed
so and this is true for all of them
except for the binomial point process
which is the only one that has a fixed
number of points
and generates what is in the system the
equivalent of random point or random
geolocation
all of the rest generate a variable
number of points
with variable distribution um
the the second simplest in some sense
is the inhomogeneous person point
process and and this one has a
a density that might vary from point to
point
and although it's very simple because
points are still independent from each
other it's very general it
it allows us to to
to it allows us to
represent loads of different types of
data i'm just going to move on because
i'm
running out of time okay
let me check the the chat one second
okay good um so for some point press is
the simplest process
points are uniformly distributed over
the observation region
they're independent from each other and
this last condition requires that the
number of points
in fact is not fixed and furthermore
poisson distributed
it is defined by its density lambda
which is the mean number of points per
unit measure
to sample from a point from from a
process when we specify a region
and we have been putting a lot of work
into making sure that the integration
with the geographic framework is as good
as possible and as fast as possible
so i'm gonna i'm gonna and these are the
most interesting examples i'm gonna show
an example from my home region which is
madrid
um so we specify the region we specify
the density by giving by
giving and the number of points that we
on average we we want to
have divided by the measure of the
region
and so the density will be
0.0112
points per square kilometer and now we
can sample
from the region and
the sample has 106 points which is not
100 because
100 will be the average this number is
poison distributed
and we can see that it they're all
within the region of
madrid so
let me move on to the next slide um
let's use it to model real world data
let's look at the towns
in madrid and we can see what the
largest towns are by population
um which happens to also be now the
ranking of covet cases in in the whole
spain right now
disastrously um
so we can see that we have 182 towns in
madrid
individual towns we we create this point
spatial point
data region the spatial point data
structure by
giving it the read the the points and
the region
otherwise as corsair was talking about
we will
generate the i'm not muted right
this is okay i'm seeing a weird thing
either
we will see the the
we will generate this the ripley
restaurant observation region which is a
dilation of the convex hull
so this is a plot of the actual towns in
madrid and we see that this
like uh a big gap around the center of
madrid because it
it's a big it's the big town the the
capital and there are also gaps where we
have
parks and stuff um and
one thing we can do is is this can we
can we
can we conclude that this is reasonably
uh spatially uniform so we can this is
something
showed as well we can apply spatial
randomness test
to the town location so we ask for the
p-value and the test conclusion
uh and we the p-value is more but well
it's it's
it's much bigger than zero so
at this confidence level we can say that
we
the the this data could be random
we we know it not to be but it could be
um at least using the chi-square test
we can also estimate the parameters of
the process
um and uh
we for this we get we get a density
that is point to the estimated density
here is
0.02 uh points per
square kilometer and using this
estimated process we can we could ask is
this is it reasonable to
to to conclude that um
there's a reasonable to conclude that
it's actually
generated by this process
and this is something i'm going to
evaluate because i want to i want to
show
i want to show the
the
this is something we've been putting
some work into
um
i hope it works
so uh and this is not fully
in there's still more functionality we
wanna
where we wanna add these user interfaces
but
i'm gonna do a small number i just
wanted people to show that
there's some feedback a lot of the
functionality here is using monte carlo
methods numerical methods and there's
some feedback
in to the user of the things that are
gonna take some time
um and this would be like
this test would be too conservative
because we're using a process that
we previously estimated from the data
but
it's more of a sanity check and i just
wanted to show the
the the user interface
um let me talk about the inhomogeneous
on-point process now
um it's basically the same as the
poisson
process but the the density isn't
homogeneous
as it says in the name and it's varying
from point to point and this is a very
general process and allow us to
represent process known parametrically
so we can we can use we can do the
up the voronoi point density that uh
gauss has shown earlier
and we can use this voronoi point
density
which gives us a point density function
to sample
from an inhomogeneous percent point
process and
and this will give us
a real a realization of this process
that has this
non-constant this non-uniform density
and we can see
here that uh this is both the data and
the sample
have gaps and
are more dense in the same places which
is
which is um reassuring
okay one can also use a we can also use
just any non-negative function as a
point
density this didn't happen
okay um
so for instance this this this
exponential
i'm going to use an extreme function to
show that uh
we can when we sample from this we'll
get like a very skewed distribution that
is heavily weighted to
towards the top here and slightly to the
right uh
so here i'm showing the contour diagrams
of the density
and the and the sampled points in this
region
there's loads of points at the top
almost no points at the bottom
okay let's move on
okay now we get to the more interesting
process the
i'm first going to talk about the
interacts per interacting gifts
processes
these have a pairwise repulsive
interaction reposter because if they
were attractive
they wouldn't be stable they would just
keep generating
more and more points
we have a general gibbs process called
gibbs point process which is a very
general object
which is the equivalent of an indian
homogeneous poisson point process
and it takes a general density and pair
interaction
and will generate an arbitrary gibbs
point process
um the issue is that
uh it's it's less optimized than
the common we we have also
implemented the common gibbs processes
which are more optimized
and estimate you can you can do
estimation and sampling much faster than
for the gibbs point process
so the the an easy way to characterize
these
interaction processes are by looking at
the
the pair potential potential describes
the uh radial interaction
between two points closer than than
than a radius uh when
the value of a value of zero means that
there's no interaction so that's the
effectively interacting radius and
infinity means that
they can't you can't have any
points closer than that so for the
hardcore point process this is
exactly what we see but then we have
other softer chord point processes
like the strauss point process which is
the canonical soft core
um interacting process a mixture of both
the structural
compo hardcore point process and then
um other more subtle interactions that
might be useful in different cases like
the pentine indica graton and diggle
gates
point processes
let's look at one of the simplest
interacting point processes the hardcore
point process
um here points are distributed uniformly
with density
lambda but they're not allowed to be
closer than radius r of each other as i
was saying before
an example i looked at from real world
data's
pharmacies in madrid in madrid that are
not legally allowed to be closer than
150 meters walking distance
uh just looking at pharmacies closer to
my home this data i got from my
government website
you can see points these points
represent the pharmacies
um and it's always useful to see
could this be just a poisson process and
in this case
again we see that it is um
so but still we know that we have
prior knowledge that suggests that
actually a hardcore point process is a
better fit
for the for the data and it gives more
interaction
more information about the underlying
mechanism
the the fact that in fact they're not
allowed to be closer than a certain
distance
um so we can
estimate the process and this will give
us the
density and the the
and the minimum hardcore radius which we
can convert to
units in my own country um
50 meters 43 meters this is
the difference is partly due to to the
fact that it
some of them might not follow the law
this is
uh not not that
rare in spain and some of them we're
actually looking at
uh distances uh
geometric distances as the crow flies as
opposed to
walking distance okay
uh let me skip this one
this slide let's talk about uh about
another process which is a little bit
more interesting which is the
strashpoint process um which has a soft
core
and let's look again at the towns in
madrid i showed earlier
and and it's say it's reasonable that we
can model the distribution of towns
by saying that towns are likely not to
be too close to each other because
otherwise they would just become a new
town that is a bit bigger one of them
would
eat the other town um the simplest model
for this kind of soft core repulsion is
is the stress model which has a constant
penalty
photons being closer than a radius are
so we can estimate the data
and this is something that i want to run
to show the interface as well
it's pre-computing some data to start
the yesterday and
now we'll start the estimation and again
we have this
nice we have this nice user interface
and the oh that was too quick but
it's trying to mix minimize the pseudo
lock likelihood and it gives
and it gives us these parameters
we can see that uh it's estimated
even though the mean point density is
0.022 it's estimated slightly higher
density
as a parameter but then there's this
there's this responsive interaction that
actually lowers the number of points
and it's it tells us that there's
actually two
the the strauss radius is the
interaction radius is two kilometer
two kilometers approximately two
kilometers and we can see this in this
visualization where we see that most of
the towns
are in fact outside of this radius but
some of them are closer
and there are these overlaps and they're
allowed to be closer just
there's there's a penalty for it
okay i need to be quick uh okay i'm
almost done
um so
let me talk about the general gibbs
point process uh which is
uh as i said earlier further
generalization of the homogeneous
post-on-point process
and it takes an arbitrary point density
and a pairwise interaction
and this power is there's also you can
also take a general
interaction density and there's actually
several
different ways of of specifying the
interaction that i'm not going to talk
about now
um for instance uh let's just
give the pure potential of the hardcore
point process but instead of a
constant the the the
the constant density hardcore point
process we're going to give it a
varying density so let's simulate
let's simulate
uh a hardcore point process where the
where the and this is the potential of a
hardcore
point process it's infinity if it's
smaller than the perpetrator's
infinity if it's more than a radius and
let's just uh use a density that again
is exponentially increasing so that this
the bias towards one end
of the observation region we can
generate the points
and we can see that
which is the points and this is the the
picture
we have uh there's no points that are
closer than the
than the hardcore radius essentially and
this
this all of them are to one corner of
the
of the observation region um just to
show that this
uh we can also compute the point density
again of this sample
uh using uh for instance the voronoi um
density and we can use this
as a we could use this to generate the
the the
the new data and this would be less
exact but because
the so so it what i'm saying is that
gibson
also takes non-parametric densities uh
because this just behaves like any other
function
so we can give it to the to the sampler
and it will generate
the data and because the this is
piecewise constant the the sampling is
actually a little bit faster in this
case it took
six seconds earlier now it takes two
seconds
okay um i should i should wrap up
okay um the third family that we have
upon person the cluster processes uh
here clusters
um who centers themselves from a point
process are used to generate
upon process around each center
uh we have the general name and squat
point process which is a general poisson
cluster process
with with where the both the the
the seeds themselves and the number of
points
in the clusters are poison distributed
and uh we also have implemented a family
of common
name and scot process like we did with
the gibbs and these
can be understood by looking at the
radio distribution
they differ in the radio distribution so
we have the martin point process which
has uniform
radio distribution so they're
uniform inside a circle around each seat
the thomas point process is normally
distributed radially
cauchy point process has a heavy tail a
cautionary distribution
so the points where we are
can be much further away from the center
and we also have a the variance gamma
point process which
has a normal gamma mixture for the
radial distribution
okay so let's look at an example right
before i finish off the thomas
let me look at chat uh
okay okay
yes eduardo you have some chat um in
zoom
yes i i will i will i will upload the
notebook
i'm gonna load the notebook um
[Music]
yeah i will i just i've been making
changes to it the last second so that's
why i haven't done it yet but i will
after the talk um
so yeah i just finished with an
application uh the cluster pro
point process can be used to model
ep real epidemiological
processes like for instance covet spread
uh the thomas point process i'm gonna
use here
um we're gonna use it to model a cough
droplet distribution around the
population of infected people
so and this is because the
the radio distribution is normal which
is reasonable to assume that
there's more cough droplets closer to
the person
that is infected than further away so we
can specify the parameters like this i'm
going to assume that we have a room
that's
10 meters by 10 meters and i have only
one infected person that is one of these
super contagious people
um and let's assume it it it gives
they give away a thousand cough droplets
per infected person and the
reach of these droplets is two meters
which is the distance they're always
telling
us to to stay away from each other
so we can sample this and we can see
that
um each each time we sample from this
process we'll get a different
distribution of uh
and sometimes it will be you know
sometimes we'll
it will be it'll be in the center
sometimes there'll be more than one
person it depends
um and we can compute with this we can
compute the mean point density of the
of the
of the cop droplets in this case 10. and
here the question is like is this a big
number i don't know because
i'm not an epidemiologist but this is a
tool that
that can allow an epidemiologist to to
figure out if this is a number that will
where someone is likely to get infected
or not um
we can also use one of the second order
statistics that we have
to to look at the this
this will give us the probability empty
space f will give us the probability
that we have
um that we we're in contact a radius r
to at least one of these cough droplets
and we can see that the and this is for
the for the whole room
and we can see that above uh
above a very small radius above a few
like a quarter of a meter
we're likely to be we're a meat
really above a meat a half a meter we're
very very likely to come into contact
with one of these cough droplets so
being in a close room
is bad news um it seems for kovit
okay um i think this is the
end of my talk uh this is functionality
that is coming
with 2.2 finally we have
been leveraging all the geographic and
geometric functionality more from
language to implement all of this and
integrated
we've put a lot of work into optimizing
different cases implemented different
data structures to make sure that all
these computations are as fast as
possible
and we hope that people like it and
enjoy it i'm going to finish now
okay questions
i think eduardo those were only sent for
us to see so you might want to read the
question before you answer it because i
don't think all the
other members can see the questions
okay i'm seeing the ones in the chat
right
in the webinar chat yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay uh so jose is saying any good
reference for gang style with spatial
statistics
especially with mathematica well this is
stuff that we're just releasing so
hopefully our documentation
we were striving it to be the place
for it when it comes out um
yeah but there are some good books out
there
as well uh
i can send you reference i don't know i
don't remember the name of the books but
bylay has is has done a lot of
a lot of work on this uh and then let me
see
can you load the video okay okay
that's it that's the only question okay
um the reference in the file
in the notebook okay i'll add the
references then notebook
i guess okay great
okay thank you all for attending my talk
i hope
it was interesting bye
uh there's another question wait there's
another question in the chat by
by seth chan yes sorry okay so
yeah yeah yeah and this is zoom many
menus yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay so seth yes the p-value
test was a problem
the publish itself isn't is you know it
takes population density into account
um well i think the
the the the p-value test that i did in
the in my talk was
was a problem because i had estimated
the the
the the process from the data itself and
then
and then tested for it and that is so
that will
that will that will give me a better
result than if i
hadn't made a correction our probability
uh probability framework corrects for
this but this is
very this is like an open research
problem and it's in fact
very very hard to cur to to it
this is not this is still an open
problem and people don't know how to do
this yet
uh so this test is only
really works um
if you already know the process that
you're testing against
nevertheless as with opi valley tests it
will
it really helps you to reject data
categorically more
i think it's useful if you get a very
small p-value
you know that the data is not
distributed
according to the process but if you get
up a p-value that's not that small
is it's nothing you can't really say
anything about
the fit um
okay let me continue reading is the
clarify suppose files
okay so what you're talking about with
the river
nile river delta um
well one of the ways to do this would be
to have the observation region
a lot like a narrow strip along the
the river and that would that would in
fact
um take care of that another way of
doing this is with
something that's called covariates which
is something that we haven't that we
it's not coming out
um in this release of the functionality
but there's a way to basically
uh correlate with data that is
extrinsic to the point pattern itself
to the point collection itself um
um has this been applied to cosmological
data yeah this is
this is one of the fields where this is
all comes from actually
like the the cluster processes are
strauss was a cosmologist or something
like that so yes
yes um
yeah yeah cover it's for for version 13
yeah hopefully i don't want to i don't
wanna commit to
a number but yeah um okay
uh another uh okay
okay i think this is all okay
thank you thank you again guys take care